so what should the future ideally look
like that
very big question
the future is
any futures it's not just one thing we
have this notion that ever since we've
been able to see the earth from the
outside and because we now have a
dialogue around issues like global
consciousness a collective environmental
fate a world economy the possibility of
nuclear war as if there is one future
but for most people on an individual
level most of the time their future
still feels very different from that of
other people we live in a world for
example of enormous income inequality
right so even though there is a global
economy it certainly doesn't feel like
one's sort of day-to-day fate or destiny
is linked to those of people around the
world even if it is in very invisible
kinds of ways so you know the notion
that there is one future is very
difficult to sort of absorb and to enter
to sort of deal with and come to terms
with so I think we're maybe moving
closer in that direction a hundred years
ago these kinds of issues around a
global environmental system and global
security order and so forth we're very
difficult to fathom and weren't really
part of day-to-day discussion so we're
getting closer and closer to the idea
that there is one future but I think
we're still probably a long way away
from it if your question is what should
it it look like if there were one future
you know I have my own views of course
about how you know the world should not
be governed by the sacrosanct principle
of national sovereignty based on
triticale principles but rather on
different kinds of communities that
demonstrate the capacity for
responsibility whether those are you
know agrarian communities and villages
whether they are internet-based cloud
communities whichever kinds of
identities and networks exist that allow
people to fulfill themselves should be
part of what we enable and empower
people to to achieve and to strive for
your advice for
the next generation being so my advice
to the next generation what you might
call Generation Y or even generation Z
today's toddlers is certainly too you
know realize that they have a capability
to explore the entire world much more
than ever was the case before and that
the you know the physical limitations
are really diminishing you know our
generation or our parents generation
grew up in a world that was very
politically divided it was very
difficult to cross certain borders if
not impossible today those borders are
really coming down there's almost really
not a single country in the world left
that you're not allowed to go to that
you can't get access to all societies
are opening up in varying degrees to
globalization which is the spread of
ideas of Technology of economics of
supply chains so it is really remarkable
that that this generation can really
experience the world and inform an
impression you know much more broadly
than their parochial context in which
they've grown up I think that's
extremely important to explore that as
much as possible the other thing is that
the expectations around certain career
trajectories have really changed now one
used to grow up and say well I have to
study to be a doctor or banking or
medicine or law in these rigid kinds of
ways and today we find that there's an
enormous amount of creativity and scope
for for creativity that that's possible
and very successful people today are
those who have some experience in the
private sector or some experience in the
public sector some experience with civil
society organizations all at the same
time you know or even forming bridges
across those to pursue certain goals
certain objectives whether there are
noble humanitarian missions or or
whatever the case may be so I think that
is another example of how there's so
much potential for young people today